I'm looking at my DNA results,
and I need answers.
( music playing )
Coming soon, five new episodes
of "Glad You Asked"
exploring the impact of race
in society on our health.
Good morning.
So I'm stopping breathing.
- 4.7 times an hour.
- Headphones on.
It's so loud.
I feel like I don't know
what I'm doing.
So an idea that came
from slavery
has lingered in the medical
field through to today.
Is there a difference
between race in medicine
and racism in medicine?
Oh, hell, yeah.
What does all that noise
mean for our health?
You may have
a hearing problem.
A single exposure
for even a fraction of a second
at 140 decibels could be
sufficient to cause that
instantaneous damage.
What happens to us
when we lose sleep?
What is this?
For one week
go to bed when you're tired.
and then wake up
when you are rested,
but no alarm clock.
That sounds amazing.
( yawns )
I'm so tired.
How come so many people
aren't accessing therapy?
You know, just like the rest
of society has to do the work
in order to be anti-racist,
the same has to happen
in the therapeutic space.
It's really hard to separate
out my desire to have kids
versus the expectation
to have kids.
Our biology does not keep up
with our social progress.
"Glad You Asked,"
an all new season coming soon.